i interview a lot of
actors and directors and so i'm i'm
hitting you with the same kind of
questions that i ask them which is
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
the office is like one of my favorite
shows of all time and i would have
loved to uh you know maybe be a part of
like the sports agency that jim and uh
jim and daryl went and worked at later
on in li or later on
in the show um or you know something i
would have been a janitor i would have
been anything really i
t guy whatever god is that one of those
shows that like is your friends you
could just watch it endlessly
yeah i mean i've probably seen i've seen
it through from beginning to end
at least like eight times uh oh wow okay
we're talking super fan yeah yeah i know
i know too much
no too much got it uh what movie or
movies do you think you've seen the most
uh super bad old school
wedding crashers i love you man for
getting sarah marshall
dumb and dumber okay i think i figured
out your humor
yeah it's pretty pretty pretty uh
pointed there right
in an emergency you have to leave your
house
what's the pair of sneakers that you
grab like what's that one pair
that you grab and why what
oh that's a great question um i think i
grabbed
the jordan one low um it's like the dior
jordan one lows i think those are like
my favorite pair right now
uh sneaker culture is never been bigger
than it is right now
um how many pairs do you think you
actually have
and i am curious what's the most you've
spent on a pair of sneakers
oh man um
it's not this not very much because for
i've been a jordan
um athlete for a long long time so i get
all the jordans
fortunately um so like that's
what i wear i have to ask you is it rude
if i if i put up my middle finger at you
right now i'm sorry
yeah no it's not rude at all i
understand it how many pairs do you
think you
have oh man that's like
uh 300 probably easy
got it that's actually i try to do a
good job of like if i haven't worn them
for a while or i don't like
really like wear them a lot i try to
give them away like give them to people
so
i feel like it could be way
worse than that but the thing is like i
have found i'm not a big sneaker head
but i know a lot of people that are
uh i have found that if you wait like 10
20 years everyone wants that pair
so is it sort of like do i want to give
this away or i just want to hold this
for 20 years and it's going to be super
cool
for me it's space like not only is it
shoes but i also wear size 16 so they
take up even more room
and so it's like where do you put them
like i i know some guys that dedicate an
entire
uh guest room and they build out a guest
room like
closet shoe closet but i i haven't done
that i do have a lot of sneaker space
um but i just have to i got to find
space for them
i get it i would imagine one of the
perks of your job is if there's ever
a pair that you really want that's like
super rare it's just a phone call away
that is that is one of the perks and and
i've been i've been fortunate to get
most pairs that i
that i want yeah again middle finger um
i get it
right one of the things about you is you
take care of yourself with
sports and nutrition what do you wish
like you knew early in your career that
someone had told you
man that's a great question i love that
question um
i well i sort of did this but i saw i
was a health and exercise science major
in college
i wish i had just really done a deep
dive and i and i do this
i do it more now but i wish i had
started earlier um you know
trying to meet with people who who are
at the top of their field in
in health and exercise science and pick
their brains on what do we think is best
because
you know there's all these things i feel
like when i came into the nba
strength training and and certain things
that we use are not even
used today and this was like 10 years
ago
it wasn't necessarily like oh yeah 30
years ago things were different this was
like
not that long ago and even beyond that
it was like five years ago it was
different so like things are changing so
much that
i really probably would have tried to
stay more
on top so that i'm not reacting um that
i'm just sort of like staying on top of
those trends because
you know we're learning stuff about our
bodies and then how we can compete
better and
and longer and be stronger and
bigger faster stronger all the time i am
completely blown away by what tom brady
has accomplished
um and i'm just curious do you think
it's the food and the science
or did he make a deal with the devil i
think he made
i think he maybe made the deal over some
healthy food
and you know you know it's the science
as well but yeah i mean
it's it's unbelievable i mean you know
lebron has sort of had that same like
sustained like
long period of being very very good and
it's it's
so so impressive um i think a lot of
things have to go right
i mean um you know but he
those guys like put in the time and tom
brady puts in the time and the work and
the money
um to to get to this point and you know
you see why
he's also very talented i've seen driven
yeah no i mean he
he's operating on a completely different
level and my last thing before getting
into the show
uh i know that you must be competitive
with video games and you know i'm sure
you're
looking at what your stats are and
whatever game it may be have you ever
asked
your agent or manager to make a phone
call and be like look
blake needs to have that number adjusted
that is not acceptable
i haven't i have not yet i sort of uh
if it's lower than you think that you
think it should be you i kind of like
try to use it as motivation
um so i i haven't yet but
now that you say that you know i need to
make a phone call
god um so jumping into the show um what
was it first of all why
are prank shows so beloved by everybody
i love those shows i can watch them
endlessly
i don't know i i just i don't have a
great answer but like impractical jokers
is one of my favorite shows
because i just i can just turn it on and
watch it for hours on end
and prank shows the same thing i i don't
know i
i just i love them um and i love this
idea of taking the
person who's always pranking somebody
and turning it around on them
um and it made for like really great
television because you can have
camera angles and you know if somebody
sees the camera it doesn't matter they
both think they're
the one that's in on it so it really
lends itself to great content and
i i don't know it's just a guilty
pleasure of mine and i hope people like
it as well
yeah that's the thing i think that's
really cool about your show is that
you don't have to hide the cameras every
like
you're getting willing participants who
don't realize they're
you know the double cross so you know
what i mean anyway
i thought that you know was it easier to
recruit people like could you sort of
talk about that aspect of it
uh as far as the people that were we
were the pranksters and the prankies or
whatever
uh yeah uh i don't i don't know i mean
like the casting department did such a
great job of finding people
you know there were obviously hidden
cameras because you couldn't have
everything out in the open it
would be questions but like we got so
much footage from like our our
our fake uh stunt guy uh or our fake
prank like producer you know asking them
like one-on-one footage
and um like that
that lends itself really well as well
our like
from top to bottom our cast was
unbelievable like everybody that was
working behind the scenes every
all the actors that were in there um did
an unbelievable job and and
a lot of livers of so many moving parts
to like pull this off
but it was impressive to to to see and i
was like
i was like super just pumped to be a
part of that that crew
did you have new respect after making
this show for what ashton kutcher pulled
off
with pranked years ago absolutely
absolutely
because it's uh things can go wrong like
not wrong and like oh no like this is
really bad but like
you know if somebody's not in the right
spot or somebody's late or somebody says
the wrong thing or
turns the wrong way you know it can sort
of mess things up so
yeah i definitely have respect for for
ashton kutcher for many reasons but
one for yeah for what he did in punk
um how close did any of these come to
someone really
like freaking out or getting angry or
you know what i mean like
because you have to monitor someone
could easily fly off the handle
yeah there was a couple where i was i
was a little bit worried about it
but not not to a point where like they
were really gonna like
hurt somebody but just that like if they
were gonna get a little bit too angry
maybe throw something
um but like our actors did a great job
of like
controlling those situations and making
sure that you know nobody was getting
too worked up and
and you know they kept them in this like
moment of like
suspense where it's like what like you
know what is going on here
but you keep them in that moment as long
as possible to try to get all these
reactions
and then you know when we had to we
would reveal you did a few episodes of
this series
um if it ends up being a hit are you
planning on doing more
yeah if we're if we're lucky enough to
do more i'm yeah i'm definitely
definitely excited to do more it's it's
also great you know i was talking to
somebody about this it's great because
now i've gotten a chance to watch these
episodes
and like there's already so many things
where i'm like i'll do this different
this different this different
um not that i'm not happy and proud of
what we did
but like i just know we can make it even
better
um so hopefully we get that opportunity
yeah a lot of people don't realize
making the first season is just also
about putting the infrastructure in how
do we do this
how do what's our editing technique like
what are we looking for
and then the second season is always
better in terms of the infrastructure
exactly there's all there's like already
so many things that i i'm looking
forward to if we get that chance
uh switching gears again i want to go
back to some other things
what was the last time you think you
were like really nervous before a game
and why before a game
i would probably say my first playoff
game
just because i didn't i've obviously
never been in the playoffs
and like as a young guy like
you you always hear like your vets talk
about how
different the playoffs are they're like
oh the playoffs are it's a whole
different brand of basketball
you know everybody's watching you know
the the arena's packed
um it's always against a good team
because they're in the playoffs so
i think that was the last time i was
like really nervous after that it's like
you know you're excited but i wouldn't
say nervous i'm always excited before a
game but not necessarily nervous
um one of the this is similar to a
question i asked you earlier but
for there's going to be people that are
going to watch this that are
maybe they'll be players who are in
college watching this interview
and i'm curious what advice do you wish
someone had given you right before you
got in the league
to sort of like get you ready for what
was about to happen
or did you actually get that kind of
advice from someone
i did get that advice but you know it's
that's the sort of the funny thing about
it is like a lot of times you have to
experience that advice
before you can actually apply it or at
least for me right like everybody is
saying like hey like
this is a marathon this isn't like a
sprint like you have to be patient
you got to put the time in you're a
rookie you know you as a player like
for me personally i want you want
everything to happen you want to be
that complete player right away you want
to be where you
you want to be at that end goal right
away and it's such a process man and you
have to like
really learn and really slow down and
appreciate everything that you're doing
but at the same time always be motivated
to make yourself better
and for the most part i think i did that
um
but like there was always that thing in
the back of my mind like i just wish i
could
do this and and sort of being patient
in that would have would have been
uh i guess more fulfilling or more i
guess more enjoyable not to say i
haven't had fun i've had a blast
um in my career but there's like that
anxiety and like that anxiousness and
that wanting more and more
instead of just enjoying where you're at
still working hard and
and moving forward one of the things i
would imagine
um is that every player has like a
nagging injury
that just you know you get dinged up i
would imagine being a professional
athlete all the time
how often are the like the players that
you're playing with or the league
for example like is everyone playing
with some sort of nagging injury every
night
or or am i just mistaking this no i mean
especially towards the end of the season
like there's that saying like
the injured versus hurt you know if
you're injured you can't play if you're
hurt
you can still play and i think every guy
like has like a
uh somewhere is hurting you know like
guys some guys are playing with
tendonitis some guys are playing with
like a wrist thing
so especially towards the end of the
season i would say
they're i don't it's hard to put a
percentage on i would say like
75 percent of the league like who play
like minutes like regular big minutes
um every game like has something going
on so
that's just a part of it look i can only
imagine listen
love talking with you thank you so much
uh hopefully some of these questions
were good
and um uh you know wish you nothing but
the best
thank you man i appreciate it nice
meeting you